oh I didn't see you there I'm Chris
color and you're watching game life now
today we're going to take a look at two
games that have no shortage of style res
HD from the guys who brought you
luminous and Ubisoft snow more heroes
with its over-the-top cel-shaded
ultraviolence now this is res HD there's
a small contingent of gamers out there
who believe that res is one of the best
video games ever created it I find it
hard to argue with them but you might be
wondering what the hell res even is now
I can't blame you sega released her eyes
about six years ago on playstation 2 and
nobody bought it they pulled it from the
market and it instantly became a
collector's item and a cult hit but now
it's available on high-definition on
xbox live arcade which means that if you
have an xbox 360 you can download res HD
for only about ten dollars which is way
cheaper than it went for an ebay so
what's all the fuss about imagine space
invaders crossed with a raid as you fly
your futuristic cyber organism pal
around and shoot down wireframe aliens
everything that happens your shots the
explosions around you the movements of
the enemies follows the pulsing beat of
the techno sound tracks as you progress
deeper and deeper into the levels the
sounds which start out as simple beats
and bleeps layer and layer on top of
each other to produce this incredible
wall of sound by the end of the level
one of the most entrancing game
experiences ever devised res HD ups the
ante with widescreen high-def graphics
and Dolby 5.1 surround sound and to
complete the experience you can use your
other 3 Xbox controllers as vibrators no
really though pulse to the beat of the
music rocking your body like you were
standing next to a subwoofer on a dance
floor you can put one on your back of
between the couch cushions one under
your feet and I'm not going to tell you
where to put the other one now res isn't
an especially long game if you're good
at shooters you can probably zip through
its five levels in a couple hours total
but it's such a fun couple of hours that
you
we want to go back to it again and again
just to zone out to its awesome
soundtrack and at ten dollars the value
proposition is just right yeah it's a
six-year-old game but it holds up
incredibly well we give it a 9 out of 10
if Sega wants a 10 out of 10 they can
make a sequel now if you somehow manage
to get your hands on a wii this
Christmas Ubisoft snow More Heroes is an
excellent game keep your wiimote
waggling all throughout this cold winter
that is if you're a grown-up No More
Heroes it's rated M for Mature which
means this isn't the kind of wii game
that you share with the kids or play
with grandma unless of course grandma
likes games about a assassins who curse
like sailors and gruesome decapitations
and running gags about fetish
pornography luckily those things are
right up my alley No More Heroes puts
you in the cell shaded shoes of Travis
touchdown an anime otaku who decides to
become an assassin after you guys a
lightsaber off of ebay haha i say
lightsaber beam katana is what it's
probably we know what they mean now most
of the game is spent hacking thugs to
death with your lights it beam katana
sorry now you're not just swinging the
Wii Remote around like an idiot to swing
your sword you just whack away at the a
button to launch into combo moves and
then finish the enemy off with one big
swing every now and then yeah it's
definitely a button masher of a sword
fighting game but there's great payoff
as measured in gallons of cartoon blood
I would jump out of my chair sometimes
in place standing up because the action
just felt so great Travis's goal is to
become the country's top hit man by
killing all of the other top ranked
assassins like a precocious japanese
schoolgirl or a magician who actually
saw his people in half there's lots of
well directed and very funny cinematic
scenes to wrap around these fights with
some excellent voice director don't die
on it too quickly I want to gorge myself
on the sense of fulfillment till I have
vomit
the action gets a little repetitive
sometimes even with the addition of odd
jobs you can do around town to earn
extra cash and there is a big open city
to explore although there's really
nothing to find there besides more
fights and the city isn't exactly
rendered in next-gen splendor actually
the graphics are kind of bad and the
draw distance is laughable but since
it's not really that important to the
gameplay it's easier to forgive
especially since the characters are so
nice and drawn ultimately that's how I
feel about no more heroes I can forgive
the budget level graphics or slightly
repetitive action because it nails all
the big picture stuff the fighting feels
great the writing is hilarious and that
the style is really really cool and
that's what matters we give it an eight
out of ten well mad about does it for
our first episode now on next week if we
actually get our copy of super smash
brothers brawl then we'll have a video
feature on that and if not well hey also
next week is the game developers
conference so definitely check that out
till next time i'm chris kohler
four-game life
you